Please welcome
[inaudible]
it's really great to be here today and talk about a lot of different things.
And I was one of those kids that was kind of different,
uh,
growing up,
bullied and teased in school.
Well,
and the thing that saved me was my science teacher.
I had a great science teacher that got me interested in doing all kinds of
interesting projects,
which brings it down.
Do you want to get kids doing interesting stuff?
You're going to have to show them interesting stuff.
There was a scene on the HBO movie where I got really interested in optical
illusion rooms.
Well and I actually saw that optical illusion Rome on a bell labs,
16 millimeter movie.
Now I'm showing how long ago that wides on optical illusions.
So you know,
gotta get 'em out there and show him stuff.
Now the thing is I want to do is to get you thinking about different kinds of
minds that think differently.
You know,
when I was in twenties,
30s,
early forties,
I thought everybody thought the same way that I think.
Then I asked this question and this is where I learned how thinking can be
different access your memory on a church steeple.
How does that information come into your mind?
I was shocked to find out that a lot of people get this vague,
generalized thing.
I don't have any vague generalized thing.
I only have specific ones.
Now you might ask,
why am I talking about Church steeples on,
why don't I ask how her,
well most people are so familiar with their own home with their own car that
they're going to see that,
but I wanted to ask you something.
You don't own what the out there and you have to see them and everybody knows
what they are.
You don't,
so you have to see a whole lot of them.
You just can't even drive around without seeing them.
And that really started giving Michigan role insight that different people think
differently.
So then I divided the world kind of into on people are thinking words and people
that think in pictures and then I started to,
well wait a minute,
this is other kind of person that kind of thinks in patterns.
This is more of the mathematical kind of mind now.
One is something they come and abnormality.
You know,
you get a little bit of the autism trait,
you take out some social stuff in the brain.
Yeah.
And you get geeked,
uh,
traits for all kinds of fun tech stuff.
I think a brand can either be made more confident of a more thinking or brain
can be made more social because after all,
who invented the first stone spear?
It wasn't the Yak,
Yak surround the um,
the campfire,
that's for sure.
Now with some geek out there in the back of the cave,
chipping away at a rock and figured out how to get it fast into a stick and that
make a stone spear.
You see,
you get a little bit of that kind of watches him trait.
You get some advantages,
you get too much of a trait.
You got a very,
very handicap because one of the big problems we've got with the autism spectrum
is it's so huge.
At one end you have got a lot of people,
probably people like Tesla who invented the power plant and you got a lot of
people in Silicon Valley.
There's a lot of them that alive.
I don't talk about life once.
I'm only in our talk about dead ones.
When I showed her pictures,
you know who all the live ones are.
You going to look a lot businessweek magazine and it's really,
really obvious,
but you get a little bit of um,
you know,
you have to creative people while you're there.
There tends to be relatives have on people that may have bipolar disorder,
you just more techies and they um,
autism careers.
Now the thing is an autism diagnosis is not precise and over the years they kept
changing the diagnosis and the early nineties,
they put an Asperger's.
We're now just geeks nerds with no speech delay become autistic.
Then in 2013 they took that out.
So now you've got this great big mucky autism diagnosis that goes from heads of
silicon valley companies down to people that are,
remain nonverbal and cannot dress themselves.
So you've got this huge spectrum.
Okay,
maybe that's Harrison and I put his picture up here,
but I promise that I would only talk about dead ones and stuff I could dig off
of publicly available things like a very popular book that's out now.
Now the thing I want to get you to think about is what happened the Little
Albert today,
Little Albert Einstein,
he had no language until he was three years old,
wasn't very social like the lineup blocks.
He'd probably be labeled autistic spectrum today.
You know,
um,
little stating,
oh,
weird loner.
This is right out of publicly available information.
A weird,
weird loner that brought snakes to his elementary school and turn them loose.
And then he was bullied and bullied and bullied and teased.
And what saved him was getting out in the neighborhood computer club.
This brings up a really important thing,
getting these teenagers that are kind of different now today they're getting
addicted to video games,
sometimes getting addicted to video games and get an autism diagnosis and get
paid social security to play video games.
Yeah,
and people say,
well,
I'm too much down on video games.
Well,
I was just down at JPL yesterday and if you want to work at JPL all day and play
video games at night,
I don't have a problem with that.
What I'm getting concerned about is the kid that's getting addicted to video
games and they're not getting a job at JPL,
that concerns me very,
very much.
And so he was bullied and then when he went to work for Atari was such a filthy
slob.
They made them come in at night not being a filthy slobs,
not okay.
And there's a scene in the movie where they slammed down the deodorant and they
said,
you stink.
Use it.
That actually happened.
This is where you know,
you know,
this were bosses,
they're going to just have to give some instruction on how to behave at work and
being an absolutely filthy dirty slop.
I don't think he'd be very acceptable here either.
It's just too gross.
Now I like the look at personality differences or of like a music mixing board.
You know,
it's not black and white.
Like if I get a diagnosis for tuberculosis,
that's definite.
I either got tuberculosis or don't or the that had tuberculosis or I didn't.
So I checked the Australian customs form,
which I did two months ago.
I can check.
I have never had tuberculosis.
That's definite,
you know,
and it's see autism,
it's a,
you know,
that's a much more gray area.
Geeks and nerds,
one this that turned into mild autism,
no black and white dividing line.
It's a continuous trait.
And if you've got rid of this trait completely,
you won't have any new employees.
It's just that sentence.
Now I am a total visual thinker.
I think in photo realistic pictures,
I don't think in words.
So when I think about designing something,
I can test run it.
And see it in my head in three d,
You know,
before three d virtual reality,
computer programs were invented.
Like I sit in a conference room and they could sort of like try stuff and they
say,
well yeah,
if you do that,
that's not going to work.
And you might wonder why as the shooed curved.
Well,
as the cattle come on around the band,
they think they're going back to where they came from and that's one of the
reasons why that works.
I'm always get asked that all the time.
Questions like the cows,
no,
they're going to get slaughtered.
I had to answer that question very early in my career and I found they behaved
exactly the same way at a slaughter plant as they behave going up a shoot for
the veterinarian.
It's not stress free,
but the amount of stress they have in both of those places is approximately the
same.
In fact,
I just updated that literature for my class slides and it's still the same.
No,
they tell us to do a blood samples in both places.
Yeah.
It can vary from very little stress from a higher stress,
but it's about the same in the two different places.
Well,
when you're aware a geek,
one of the things I've found is that the way that I had to so myself was by
showing off my work.
Yes.
Selia work rather than yourself.
So I'll put portfolios together.
Okay.
I'd say the quality of this projectors about medium good.
You know,
I've had had ones where it showed up better than that.
Now the thing is,
when I first started out,
I'd go to the AG engineering meeting and they thought I was really,
you know,
we are,
no one wants to talk to me.
And then I whipped out a big foldout drawing.
Then I started to get respect.
That's selling your work.
And the thing I learned about my portfolio,
you want to make a portfolio where someone looks at it and 30 seconds later
it's,
wow,
don't put too much junk in a portfolio.
You just put enough stuff in there.
So look at it really quickly.
Wow.
This person really has some,
uh,
you know,
really can do some stuff now.
I used to joke around that I had huge Internet access to my visual cortex.
Well it turns out I've got a pretty big circuit there and that's probably in the
top 10% or so of on circuits.
And they um,
you know,
going from the frontal cortex all the way deep to the back of the visual cortex
where the graphics files are stored.
Now,
Walter Snyder,
the University of Pittsburgh as a new scanning technology,
which I'm sure some Asperger people had to develop the computer to enable this
scanner to track white matter fibers.
So your brain's got the gray matter on the outside,
the inside of the brain's all white matter,
big long axons,
the all the way across the brain that form cable bundles.
And this new technology can actually dissect out the cable bundles.
It can tell the difference between a bridge.
They cross each other or an intersection.
And that took a lot I computer power and they can fit it inside a box that
Walter can pick up,
you know?
And so I'm an associate of thinker,
so I start thinking about that song and get eight great tomatoes.
And that anybody can,
that's an ancient old ad for tomato sauce.
Uh,
so that came up.
You can get lots of computing and an itty bitty box,
you know,
that's sort of how my mind works.
Okay,
now this is the cable bundle for speak.
What you see,
and it goes from the visual cortex up to the language area.
That's the normal one.
And that's mine.
And those branches you see,
you can see they've been truncated there on that,
on that rendering.
They actually go all of the brain.
So I basically have got a search engine like Google for images where you type in
keywords and I get lots of pictures and they are specific.
The thing I find so fascinating about search engines is they weren't just like
how my mind works well,
who made it search engines?
Some people in a much more linear in their thinking.
I don't like the way the search engine works.
I liked the way it works just fine.
And one of the things I got to teach my students is yet got to use all the
different key words.
All right,
let's just take cattle for example.
There's bowls,
cows,
cattle,
bovines,
Cath,
uh,
calves.
You got to use all those different words.
That's really obvious to me and I find if you use all the different Warren's you
find a lot of papers you wouldn't find otherwise.
Now the price I paid for this circuit is I have less bandwidth for the speak
what you see,
so I had,
I had speech delay,
didn't talk until age four and I couldn't get my words out there.
There's always a price.
This scanner was originally paid for by the Defense Department to look at
veterans hand injuries and if this had been an injured circuit would look like
dried spaghetti and like I broke about half of them.
I'll tell you the football players thaws and look very [inaudible].
Okay.
Now this is another scan is done at the University of Utah and presented
neuroscience meeting and the blue part is basically full of cerebral spinal
fluid.
It's full of water and you can see I've got a bay.
The asymmetry there,
I got visual thinking and my math department got trashed.
See where I think innate differences make the biggest difference is either real
deficit in something or an extreme ability and something,
yes,
there's brain plasticity,
but that's happening in the gray matter out on the edge.
Those big white fiber bundles,
I don't think he grows big axons back.
I mean that that long.
Okay.
You know,
Malcolm Gladwell says,
if you have enough practice and you have enough access to services,
anyone can learn anything.
Well,
back in 68,
Bill Gates and I had access to this exact same computer system.
I wanted to learn how to program.
It was just hopeless Algebra,
just hopeless.
Uh,
wanting to become an expert skier.
I could never keep them together.
I could get to the good intermediate stage.
I mean,
I could ski recreationally but get really good.
There were other kids,
one winter they'd be experts
and I just couldn't do computer programming no matter how hard I tried.
I agree with Gladwell about the practice and of course the access to,
um,
you know,
they'll do the teacher you,
you have to develop abilities.
This is probably one of my most important slides,
the different kinds of mines slide.
I am a photo realistic visual thinker,
an object visualizer.
A lot of people in programming are a pattern visualizer,
a spatial visualizer.
See in your brain you have circuits for one is something that's me and then
you've got circuits for,
whereas something and people that are super good at the,
whereas something instead of like located in space tend to not be so good at the
object.
Visualist affiliation and the visual son,
the pattern thinkers are also good off.
I'm good at math.
These kids often have trouble with reading.
I hear stories where I'm okay to have a handwriting problems.
They won't let them type on a laptop that's like just stupid.
Another thing that I hear that's really bad political correctness gone crazy is
you've got a fourth grader bored doing baby math and they make them do baby math
and they don't give them the more advanced book.
That's just ridiculous.
You can get into a situation where a kid may be gifted math but needs special ed
and reading.
Now I like to bust out of the silos.
You know,
everybody tends to get inside their own bucks.
Okay.
There's a tech box,
there's a farm and ranch box,
there's a gifted box and there's an autism blocks or ought or silos and I liked
it.
I kind of like pick out my speaking engagements,
so I like to get a little mixture of all these different things.
I think as I'm seeing something that kind of disturbs me,
I go to an autism meeting and a geeky little 10 year old walks up to me,
a real smart little 10 year old and he's fixated on his autism
and sometimes they get kind of a handicap mentality and they're not learning
basic stuff like saying please and thank you.
You know,
learning,
just,
you know,
basic skills kind of get over protected.
Then I go to a gifted meeting.
The same little Geeky kid comes up to me,
but he wants to tell me about what he saw under the Brock Maggi scope,
which is a really cool little children's,
a microscope.
And then I go to place like this,
all full of undiagnosed,
a little bit on the spectrum.
Avoid the labels like the plague because I might hold you back now where the
were learning about autism going can really help.
Some of you guys here is in your relationships.
You don't need to go out and get diagnosed,
but just reading about it that can help you out.
And then I go over to the farm and ranch in the meat world and I go to this big
huge meat packing plant and this is old gray haired hippie.
And he runs the maintenance shop and he's out there playing with the giant Lego
sa putting up a new cooler.
They huge concrete lego's.
You use the crane to put them up and he's pure spectrum.
But he had welding in high school with a worst things they've done in the high
schools is taken out the hands on classes.
In fact,
at JPL,
they make all the metal parts of something like the Mars Lander.
They make them there and shops and they're having problems finding,
uh,
you know,
who's going to replace the machine.
You when they were tired.
Now a third kind of thinkers,
the verbal facts thinker,
they know everything about whatever their favorite subject is and our verbal
thinker now,
so called normal people.
They are mixtures of these different kinds of thinking,
but I'm finding when you getting the autism programs,
there's an awful a smart kids that ought to get headed down a track towards
Google or JPL that the teachers and the schools are having a hard time shifting
gears,
how to deal with the nonverbal kids and then they got smart,
Geeky kids in that same class.
So really,
really big problem because I can think of kids I went to school with when I was
in college that I know are on the spectrum today,
but the problem that the parents of little kids have and the schools have,
in order to get service,
you have to have a label.
Now,
I don't think it hurts a kid when he's three to put a label on him to get speech
therapy,
but then you get the kid that's like 10 or 12 years old getting bullied in
school and he gets a label because he's getting bullied in school.
You know Steve Jobs is one of the kids who had,
well I had to take them on a lung school,
put them over in another school in Cupertino and unfortunately he had a,
he had a dad that had a machine shop.
That was another thing.
It was his salvation.
He was doing hands on things.
Now I know that Steve may not be the best thing and he mentioning here,
but I only can talk about the dead ones where I have information I've gotten off
of publicly available things like books and Business Week magazine,
which I've read carefully now in the autistic brain book.
I now show evidence that these two kinds of visualizers actually do exist.
You know today the schools are all about evidence based.
Well Marie Colson Offs Work,
surfing the Internet,
three o'clock in the morning.
I found her stuff about the two kinds of visualizers.
This pet,
a brain scan study showed that these two kinds of visualizers exist.
I was so happy when I found this because I had just observed each things just on
my own and when I did my ted talk,
I hadn't found these references yet and they weren't there.
Very easy to find.
There's kind of a biased about innate ability.
No,
everyone's not.
The same is,
yes,
there's a lot of plasticity.
You got a lot of people here in the middle,
you know,
you can get them pretty good at programming up to here or whatever,
but you probably won't get them to here and I can move back and forth in the
middle.
The gray matters got a lot of plasticity,
but then you've got the great big huge white matter cables willing to kind of
born with those things.
Okay.
There's two ways you can do the math.
You can do it the verbal way or you can do it the more visual spacial way on.
There's kids that can just do the math in their head.
The school says,
well,
you can't do that.
They don't get it that he thinks differently.
Well,
I'm saying let him do it in his head,
but we will take some precautions against cheating.
So we're gonna put them in a room stripped of everything electronic,
and if ain't do it then just absolutely fine.
Now I just want to show you something.
It's definitely not my mind that praying Mantis as many out of a single sheet up
folded paper,
no cutting,
no tape,
and what you see in the background,
that is the folding pattern.
Paypal,
look at that and go,
well,
well there's no way I could start with a square piece of paper and make it into
a praying mantis.
That's not my mind.
And here are some great little origami stars that some kids gave me.
Now they need to be in the advanced math class.
Now my thing was art and when I was in elementary school,
my ability and art was always encouraged and I was encouraged to do lots of
different things.
So it wasn't just done drawing the same horse head over and over again.
You got to take the things to fix that it on and broaden it out because you've
got to learn how to do stuff.
Other people are going to want always like to show my drawings off again and
here's a beautiful bridge that I'm Jesse Park Do.
She was kind of more moderate.
Well her favorite thing used to be electric blanket controls.
We had to get her off of that.
And while on the subject of bridges,
I think our governments are going crazy when you've got a governor and his aides
are deliberately creating traffic jams on a branch and one it looks just like
this.
This is absolutely ridiculous.
They're getting totally separated from reality,
you know,
and we have great things going on with private industry document the space
station.
But instead we have stupid thing on the news this morning about government
officials messing up traffic on purpose on a bridge.
And some dumb thing about,
you know,
I think,
uh,
you know,
sports players getting scared by their own mascot.
I mean that,
that was on the news this morning when I was having breakfast.
Think there's more important things to have on the news than that and these
people as far as causing a traffic jam on a bridge.
That's the kind of mindset of about an eight year old.
It's also something that done,
uh,
I would've learned when I was eight years old that you don't do stuff like that
cause it.
Inconvenience is other people.
You don't do those kinds of things cause he wouldn't like it.
You are in that traffic jam.
It's just that simple.
There are some other gorgeous artwork made by a person that was kind of at the
mid level on the autism spectrum.
All right,
now I'm going to tell you math people,
why you need to have us,
our minds.
One of the things that really worries me,
uh,
with all the stem emphasis and we're going to have to have Algebra now.
How can I get to college Algebra and now I got through college because thank
goodness for the educational fads of 1967 and in 1967 the required math class
was finite math,
probability matrices and statistics.
Bit more visual,
tons of tutoring.
I managed to get through it.
What the engineering mind does need the art mind cause I've learned there's
certain things the engineering mind doesn't see now what's there.
I don't know if that came from,
I don't know where it's going to satellite image.
I don't know if it's the googles or not.
I did get that off the Internet.
I certainly wasn't going to fly over it and get my own picture of the Fukushima
nuclear power plant.
Not something you want to get very,
very near.
That's for sure.
Cause sometimes the most obvious is the least obvious.
So I was getting all these newspapers,
all this stuff and reading about it on a plane.
It's,
I find this stuff interesting and what I found out why this happened,
I'm going,
how could you do this?
I can't design a nuclear reactor.
There's no way.
But if I had been drawing the concrete work for the plant and doing my side
elevation drawings,
there's no way I would've made the mistake they made.
All I have to know about a nuclear reactor is if the emergency pump fails to
work after you've scrammed it.
See it doesn't quite get turned off all the way.
It burns up and you're in so much trouble.
You're not,
it's not funny.
That's all I have to know about it.
Well,
okay,
earthquake broke all the power lines and everything and there's no electric
power to run the main stuff,
so they had to scrap it.
And what happened is the emergency generators that ran the emergency equipment,
we're in a non waterproof basement.
How could you make a mistake that basic.
Now when I was young,
I used to think well of stupidity.
No,
I found the mathematical mind doesn't see it.
I could see the water smashing out the baby blue movers and this plant was
painted baby blue of all colors.
A little clouds on the top of the boxes,
make it look innocent and pretty.
See those baby blue louvers.
We're going bust it out and two seconds later those big generators,
all electric panels underwater and it's not going to work.
There's no way I would've done that.
I mean,
I would've been going to every ship building company.
There was a sidewalk catalogs,
volume,
waterproof doors.
I want to try out all your waterproof doors.
I want to find waterproof doors.
They're really easy to open,
don't have to have training open and close them.
Close really tight.
Obvious when they're closed and it wouldn't have happened.
This is why you really need all the different kinds of minds.
You know,
I've been thinking about a lot of other things too.
You see,
cause I can visualize ways that it can break,
you know,
especially anything,
mechanical sorta stuff.
Okay.
Steve Jobs.
I went to college,
any audit,
a cleaner of the class,
which she didn't pay for it,
but it really influenced the computing and all the computers have nice fonts as
a result of that.
And he was an artist.
He developed the interface for the phones.
No one,
I know there's a lot of bad blood going on,
but the lawsuits,
I read all about that.
Steve wanting to go thermal nuclear on android.
I know all about that kind of stuff.
But again,
I can only talk about the dead ones.
So that's the reason why I have these slides.
But the point or the point I'm trying to get across is he wasn't an engineer.
This is where you need to have the art mind and the engineering minds working
together on projects.
They have complimentary skills.
Well there's a big debate right now that maybe a humanities programs are just
useless in colleges.
I was at a state about two years ago that we remain nameless,
but their governor said they wanted to charge extra tuition at the state
university for humanities classes and so on the chronicle of higher education,
David Barish said that the connection between Steve Jobs and so called useless
humanities programs such as calligraphy cannot be ignored.
Now one thing about calligraphy is it's a hands on class.
You actually have to do it and there is a need for humanities.
I thought this was really interesting.
You want evidence based science,
the Premiere Journal that um,
you know when students read serious literary fiction helps them with some of
their social skills rather than this reading the latest Stephen King or
something like that where Michael Crighton,
I have to say those kind of books I like when I'm going to long airplane flight
and it's really boring.
Okay.
Some of the other work I've done with livestock was the look at the things that
they're scared of.
Okay.
They're going up but shooting strange place,
neat plant for example.
They were afraid of a lot of little things,
shadows,
reflections,
chains,
hanging down,
seeing people standing up ahead,
things that we tend to not notice.
And if you take those distractions out,
maybe change a light to get rid of a reflection,
add a light cause I don't like going to a dark hole.
Okay.
Then they would move through the shoot more easily,
especially when it was in a strange place.
Now how many people here noticed this animal is locked on to that Sunbeam like
radar?
Raise your hand if you notice that.
Okay.
We're doing pretty good here JPL.
A little bit better than here.
Well,
see that's purely the visual thinking sort of stuff.
I know there's some people interested in animal issues,
so I think we'll talk a little bit about some of the things I've done.
When I was young,
I used to think I could fix everything with equipment.
If I could just build the right magic system,
everything will be perfect.
When I found his equipment is only half the equation,
the other half is management and management wanting to do things.
Right now I have a saying heat softens steel.
Then people like me who want to reform things can now shape it and bend it into
pretty grill work.
And when Mcdonald's back in 1997 decided they were going to um,
do something about bad stuff going on in slaughterhouses,
that resulted in a lot of change.
And it was my job to implement it.
And I came up with a very simple scoring system.
There was like traffic rules for slaughter houses and if you didn't follow
certain rules and make certain numbers,
you fail the Mcdonald's on it.
95% of the cattle dead on the first shot.
You fail the audit,
you've got to get them all dead before you hang them up on.
Only three animals are allowed.
The Moon Beller in the stunning area,
only 1% falling and if you want a real excellent score,
only 5% and get hip to the electric pride if you want.
Excellent score,
simple,
very simple.
You see these are outcome measures.
I'm not telling you how to build the plant.
They are very simple outcome measures and it worked because it was very
objective and very,
very,
very simple.
When big customers say that something's got to be changed and things are going
to change,
Walmart has just come out with a big statement that came out with two days ago
on I'd put video cameras and swine houses to make sure people aren't,
you know,
beaten the pigs up with gate rods are throwing a peg let's or doing some other,
really nasty thing like that.
I'm sure you've all seen that show undercover boss.
I think that's a great show.
I saw those kinds of bosses eyes opened up moments when on took some of the
executives from some of the large on a hamburger restaurants on their first
trips to farms and slaughterhouses.
I remember the day,
and this was back in 1999 or 1998 that time when one of the executive saw a half
dead dairy cow go into the product,
boy that was a real undercover boss moment.
I'd like to do another show called undercover legislature.
Well,
let's,
okay,
let's take it,
take people that do things like deliberately cause traffic jams and we've got a
real,
real special trailer set up for them.
Oh,
it's about 10 miles from the local Walmart and we're going to drop him off there
and we'll just have his license and his wallet and that's all.
There'll be a $50 debit card on the counter,
a Walmart Pan,
couple of beans on the shelf,
this much gas in the car.
Okay.
You report to work tomorrow of Walmart.
You're going to be there for two months and we've taken away your medical
insurance card.
You know,
let's get them get a taste of,
um,
you know what?
Some people are actually up against living in a total rarefied world.
Okay.
Oh,
look at how the horse and a zebra put an ear on each other and then the other
ear is on me.
Watch animals are all,
it's all about details,
all about details.
Well,
there's what the entrance to them thought or plan it looks like.
In fact,
I saw your great Google earth thing there.
I think I'll go Google earth a few of my jobs and that's always fun.
I to show a slide to my students and I'll say,
okay,
now tell me what I can improve here.
What is bad here?
Well,
one,
one thing that's good is inside the tunnel I got white translucent plastic.
So they're not going into a dark hole.
But the bad thing is,
and I'd say about half my students don't notice it because you've got three
people standing right where there should not be standing.
Then sometimes the most obvious is the least obvious.
Now there's evidence that in the normal human brain language covers up art and
mathematics because of the type of Alzheimer's that when the language parts of
the brain get wrecked,
art comes out for about three or four years and one van Gogh was painting starry
night.
I don't think he realized he was putting mathematics in it and there's gonna be
a new book coming out on a guy who got in a bar fight,
got bashed on the head.
Now he's a mathematician.
Studying physics sort of got to inner mathematician turned loose.
Now there's a lot of things and we don't know about the brain now.
An important thing dealing someone,
understanding someone thinks the way I do is I'm a bottom up thinker.
My approach to things,
that was my sound approach on developing equipment for livestock was a go around
and look at all of the state of the art.
Okay,
you go download all,
you get all the patents.
When we couldn't download them,
when I was doing it,
we had a right to the patent office and get them.
I was a real pain.
But you get all the patents,
you get all the state of the art,
go around visiting all these places and try to get the good ideas,
chuck out the bad ideas.
In other words,
it's bottom up thinking relevant,
top down or today.
What's happening,
especially on government stuff,
too much top down,
very vague things.
But concepts are formed by specific examples,
not as a young child.
Cats and dogs.
Okay.
All the cat pictures on this file.
All the dog pictures and this flyer,
well I was very young,
I could sort cat some dogs by size until our next door neighbor's got a
document.
Okay.
Now I can no longer use size as a visual criteria and for like cat versus stock.
So then I noticed they all had the same nose shape as they were dogs.
So that was all visual feature that every dog has got.
Everything is learned by specific example.
So how do I learn what being nice or being bad?
It no,
I mother would just correct me if I got say please.
Well say please.
That's nice behavior.
You wait politely.
Alliance,
the movie theater.
That's nice behavior.
Okay.
You want to teach something like up or down,
you got to use a lot of different examples.
They guys,
there's some kids with autism where if you say put thought in just goes in the
garbage.
They need to learn that and it could be put thought in the drawer in the
cupboard in something else,
not necessarily in the garbage can so up can walk up the stairs.
I looked it up a cup,
the plane flew up in the air.
Lots of different examples.
My thinking is associative.
Josh liked how a search engine works.
Okay,
salt.
I'm at the Chicago airport there quite often.
Okay,
I'll look at that.
Now I can start looking through Google for images in my head,
a glass structure category,
start going through that or I could start off at an airport category.
There are no generalized pictures.
You know,
this was something that when I was kind of really a breakthrough in my thinking
when I did the church steeple as my question rather than house or car,
something that people weren't quite so familiar with.
Okay.
Glass structure,
biosphere and Arizona.
Crystal Palace,
greenhouse at Colorado state.
Now when I'm on this subject,
I now I'm seeing our building.
It's now under construction.
Now I'm seeing other buildings that were under construction and the contractors
used up 25 are super valuable parking spaces for their trade worse.
Okay,
so that's how I got from glass structures to contractor trailers.
Real sore point with me.
I wasn't home when they did that.
I think I would have told I would have walked out there like I owned the place,
told him move the trailers.
But once they got established then you're just stuck with it.
Did they ask permission to put those trailers there?
I'm sure they did not.
Okay.
Airport category.
Now when you think about really big amounts of money,
let's start thinking about it in something a public and understand this is more
$5 billion and a building a new light rail on new west and I got to get the
price for that cause that's gonna be quite a lot more than $5 billion.
When that's done well we start thinking about some of these big amounts of
money.
It's something real like airport units.
Then people if kind of really put it in perspective.
So all you've got Denver Airport,
Dallas,
Fort Worth,
Minneapolis,
Atlanta,
and he got the old dungy,
old terminal.
They look worn yet and I'd be fun to explore that place.
And when I asked an astro physicist about the church steeples he saw motion of
people singing and praying.
We go,
oh wow.
Trippy.
That is definitely not my mind.
Now we'll make a category if they get used to being handled by a man on a horse,
they've learned that safe the first time they see the man on the ground.
That panic.
You see it's different.
It's a different picture.
I've learned man on the horse of safe man on grounds,
new and scary.
I can also learn that man on the ground is safe,
but that's something totally knows he most people wouldn't think the man on the
ground was something novel.
Now I find when you're trying to categorize problems and a lot of people have
trouble categorizing,
where's a problem coming from?
Okay if I got something wrong in a factory,
is there something wrong with the equipment or something wrong with how people
are operating that equipment?
I find people often don't make that differentiation.
If it's an equipment problem is just a glitch.
Of course,
if it's a meat plant and have done a lot of work with them,
she stopped trolley or fundamental design problem.
They don't make that differentiation.
I've got a problem with a kid in school.
Does he have a biological problem?
Like maybe your tummy hurts so much that he can't pay attention in school or is
he just,
I'm not wanting to do the work,
you know,
it's just strictly behavior.
Top down thinkers tend to over generalize,
especially when there aren't,
when they're not doing practical things anymore.
Well,
I got this out of,
um,
out of,
uh,
one of the tech magazines about dog fooding.
You know,
you've got to use the stuff that you make then,
you know,
really find out if it actually works.
Policy makers need to be directly experienced the consequences of their
policies.
And if you want to mess up traffic cause a traffic jam than you need to be stuck
in the middle of the worst traffic jam.
Well there the guys up at JPL and was very cool to get to meet them,
you know,
uh,
no.
Kind of unconventional.
It's okay to be eccentric.
That's okay.
One of the most creative people are really,
really accentuate.
Then doing marvelous things and then talking to the public.
We need to tell the public,
well,
what are some of the spinoffs from maybe some of the JPL stuff?
Not stuff from the 60s that's ancient history.
Let's look at inventions in the last 10 or 15 years.
How about the active Pixel Center?
The Ha the sensor.
That's the heart of the cell phone camera.
How about coding?
That's involved.
That will help one cell phone tower.
The phone to work.
One cell phone tower to another cell phone tower.
How about a mass spectrometer?
That's big.
Yeah,
we have a mass spectrometer the size of a giant desk.
Well you can put a sample in that and we'll tell you what chemicals on it.
Well that would have a lot of really good useful uses.
Now I was more interested in looking at pictures of things and pictures of
people,
but we knew people interested in things cause a social yackety yack and aren't
going to solve some of the energy problems and stuff like that.
Let's help some of the kids that are different.
I don't care if they're labeled gifted,
they're labeled quirky,
weird nerds or mild autism.
One thing you've got to do with these kids when they're young is you got to
stretch.
I'm just outside of their comfort zone.
And the other thing is we need to be learning job skills that needs to start at
age 12 we need to find paper route substitutes.
Things like walking dogs for the neighbors.
Things like maybe you know,
setting up chairs at the community center.
Something like that.
One place where all my teachers and everybody drew a line.
I wasn't allowed to become recluse in my,
in,
in my room.
That was absolutely not allowed.
I had to get out and do things.
Kids aren't doing free play,
which teaches valuable social skills.
You know,
dogs need to do this too when they're young because if dogs don't do this when
they're young,
then I fight and the dog's really efficiently has never learned how to get
along.
Taking out the hands on classes is the worst thing to schools ever did.
They took out cooking,
sewing,
woodworking,
machine shop,
welding.
We have a shortage of skilled trades.
I mean,
JPL needs people to make the wheels and stuff for the Mars lander or there's
something really cool and really geeky about the wheels of curiosity.
We don't just let you figure it out.
I don't know if I'm supposed to tell you or not,
but it's so,
it's so geeky and anti suit.
It's just really,
really cool.
Um,
but they need to have those machinists,
you know,
it's not going to work without them.
The other thing that's bad about taking out hands on classes is we are losing
resourceful problem solving.
Even something as simple as,
you know,
with cooking,
you're missing an ingredient.
Can you do it with another ingredient?
Of course in the fifties girls were taught sewing,
so I had a wonderful toy sewing machine was in fourth grade and I remember one
project where I cut the fabric wrong on a ruin it,
you know,
it was like gotten a rush.
Some of the things you learned from doing hands on things.
This is the stuff that saved me.
These were things that were refugees away from teasing kids that did the
teasing.
We're not interested in woodworking or incident riding horses.
I was also an sts model rocketer now I loved model rockets and I was in the
model rocket club and I was horrified to go on the Estos website about a month
ago and you can buy a ready made rocket.
That is disgusting.
The point is the bull bummer.
I made a few or points with the other kids when I made a rocket.
They look like our headmaster.
I'm mister paty rocket and he was aerodynamically stable on a flute
on.
I didn't do very much studying,
but I was in a special boarding school for gifted kids with a lot of emotional
problems and instead of studying I was remodeling our ski Towle house.
What the headmaster letting me do that cause I was learning work skills and a
lot of these kids are not learning work skills.
I cleaned a lot of horse stalls to an oss 15 lots and lots of them and I was
responsible for the Horse Barn and making sure it always close the feed box.
Got To always close the grain box.
The guy's horse dies.
If it eats out of the grain box,
you've got to close it.
I think we need to limit screen time.
Little kids.
I,
the thing that I'm finding with electronics and really little kids is yeah,
a little kids want to play with electronics,
but we need to get that teacher in there and get them taking turns.
These kids are got to learn how to take turns.
Well,
I think we need to start making connections,
physical connections between the virtual world in the real world and one really
enterprising mom.
She went to the lumber yard,
got some two by fours cut up and then she brought them all home to the driveway
and had the kids paint them to make Minecraft blocks in the dry fly.
Although words linking the online world to the real world.
Then our kid had rural autistic kid,
had lots of friends coming over to play with the Minecraft blocks,
activities with animals,
get kids involved in activities they can do with other kids.
Four H FFA robotics clubs,
makerbot three d printing clubs,
get them involved in these things.
My ability and art was always encouraged.
We need to be working on building up the area of strength.
You know,
the kid gets good at math and let them do more advanced classes.
Use fixations to motivate great online sources.
Now I was reading that on you,
Udacity or some of these things like this that only like 4% of the people took
the entire class.
I don't consider that a failure because there's an awful lot of people that
might want to just look at some programming stuff and just take a couple of
lessons to learn something and needed for work.
Because back when I was doing hydraulic stuff all the time,
I had all these books for hydraulics.
I didn't need Algebra because I had all these tables for things like fluid flow,
look it up on tables and I,
when I first started out I took the first book and I did read the first book
pretty well,
but I didn't read all the books.
I use them as reference books.
I think the thing they need to look at is how many of those people that went on
you.
Udacity took a few lessons as a reference and it helped them in their work.
I think that's something that needs to be looked at.
But I show this to um,
uh,
you know,
a lot of parents that they don't realize there's a lot of free stuff out there
and we got to do something about rural Internet access is beyond awful.
You cannot play videos and you go out in the rural areas,
you still got the mom and pop DVD stores because they don't have movies on the
was.
It's just that simple.
It is atrocious.
Well,
there's the optical illusion room.
I got fixated on that and the movies did a nice job of showing me,
making it,
and there's one of my designs in sketch up.
I know you don't own it anymore,
but it's a great,
I've seen some really great things going on.
Teenage kids doing sketchup and then they're printing their stuff out with three
d printers.
Really,
really cool stuff and I really liked this warning they had on the makerbot
website.
You need patients.
Yeah.
Let's kind of fiddly little machine and get mad at it if you're going to break
it.
No.
How in a sense of adventure required.
I really liked that thing they wrote on the website.
Yeah,
you don't design it right.
Your little thing's going to collapse some goo.
You know,
you're getting back to the real world.
The other thing on something like this,
people say,
well,
they can't afford that.
Okay.
It's $1,500.
$2,000 little,
the money's getting spent on sports.
That's the price of one major league football uniform.
All it costs maybe two high school uniforms.
It's not very much money.
I don't want to hear that.
And all that's just kind of neat little thing they made.
And this is some views through the Brock,
Maggi sculptor.
Great little really durable little child's microscopes.
$150,
no fiddly mirror.
Uh,
very easy for kids to use.
We don't have a glass slide and I was so happy to go to the gifted conference.
It wasn't the autism conference.
I wish this has been at the autism conference cause it's a gifted conference.
They had a hotel room about the size of this and all these kids that they put
the electronics away and they were playing with the Brock magic scope and they
have looking at pond scum and leaves and it's really cool.
Well just got to show people,
I mean you guys know about this stuff that's on the Internet,
but I do a lot of talks and a lot of places and I just want to give people ideas
of cool things that are out there.
Uh,
there's some evidence that kids are learning to write,
but it's going to help them on reading,
on learning,
reading.
Maybe you turn off all the bells and whistles and use the plain ebook,
maybe just with still pictures and you haven't read it and they're learning a
story better.
And again,
this is refereed scientific stuff.
We're going evidence based here.
Well people need to touch to perceive not a really good time over at picks her.
They finally,
sometimes they got to get them off the computers and get them actually drawing.
And when they print their figurines out on their three d printer,
they put them around the computer mouse where they can touch them.
Got To touch to see.
Got It.
Do that science teacher boy.
And he helped me out.
Well he was a NASA space scientist.
Was He accredited teacher?
No,
no.
Stupid ed courses for him.
We got to get back to doing real things in this country.
That's all we got to do.
One thing a lot of employers want the new one.
I won won today.
As you know,
students know how to work.
It just came up with a lot of things.
I learned to sell my work,
not myself.
Also in working with some of the people that are different,
you don't take that employee and go,
well,
just develop some new software.
You want to say,
okay,
I want to make an app for the android phone and it does this specific thing.
It uses this language,
this memory.
You don't tell him how to do it,
but it's got certain parameters.
Then okay,
that's easy to do and when mistakes are made,
the boss needs just pull them aside and say,
bull in the office quietly,
no yelling and screaming,
and he said,
well,
we know what the project meeting last week and you call Jim and jerk in front of
the other five colleagues.
That's not the Google way of doing things.
Just don't do that and I learned on you can get some people that will sabotage a
project due jealousy.
That was very,
very difficult for me to deal with.
And then you get other people where they just think differently,
you know like that kind of differentiate between the two.
Well if I was in in a plant,
one of my meat plant projects in a plant engineers sitting like this,
I was hired by the manager,
you didn't like this weird geek coming in on his turf.
I would kind of pull them into the project and that oftentimes stopped that.
Okay,
tour guide,
great job for 12 year olds.
You don't,
you going to demonstrate the correct distance to get from the visitor,
demonstrate the correct greeting and so it's like coaching somebody in a foreign
country
and there's sensory issues.
Some people just can't stand a lot of noise,
can't stand 60 cycle fluorescent lights and you had a lot of sensory issues and
they can vary from being very mild to being very severe.
This needs to be researched and how to treat some of these problems.
When I was a little kid loud.
Sounds hurt my ears.
I still absolutely hate the vacuum toilets and airplanes.
If I'd had to deal with those when I was five,
I would have been shrubby sucked out of the airplane.
Well,
I visual thinking mind went wild when I was like six years old and they'll
remodeling our house.
They had this big circular saw and I saw him.
I was afraid that maybe it's blade come up to the floor if my room just like
ludicrous,
but when you maybe six years old,
it wasn't quite so ludicrous.
I,
I had trouble hearing hard consonant sounds,
so my speech teacher slow down and annunciated the hard constants.
She'd say cup and then she say capa slow down and annunciate it.
So then I could hear it.
Tension shifting.
Some of this is I have problems with it.
Somebody said puts some rings,
a cell phone off I orient takes me much longer to shift back.
Tension shifting slowness.
Some people when they go to read the print,
we'll jiggle on the page.
That's probably about 10% of students that are having some trouble in college.
Doesn't explain all autism.
It doesn't define all dyslexia,
but there's something wrong with the circuits back here.
Shape,
color,
motion,
texture.
They're not merging together.
Right.
And sometimes it can be fixed on a very simple thing like Pale pink glasses,
pale lavender glasses,
different.
Partly your work on some different colored papers.
Maybe try different background on colors on the computer screen,
different fonts.
Now wouldn't it be stupid to lose her job or flunk out of school?
Do you didn't do this?
I'm finding one out of 50 Scott.
This problem with my livestock handling class because they do really horrible on
my drawing assignment.
They cannot draw.
I say draw this.
Okay,
they're drawing.
That's what the draw.
They don't say it.
Well there's my head.
Well that's all the white matter or that side inside the uh,
on the gray matter.
This is not lining up right.
Something got changed here.
I,
there should be a little space there for the gray matter.
What's said something got out of sync there on that.
And that's all the circuits.
And also you can ask is that as a cable bundles that are the Inter office
communication,
that's where you have differences in developmental problem.
Well,
my fear center was bigger than world know.
It was well,
that's controlled now with antidepressant medication.
Little protrack lost visual thinkers,
panic monsters.
Um,
I know a lot of visual thinkers.
We're a little dab of PROZAC in the morning.
I'll Lexapro Zoloft on stops the anxiety,
then you're not getting whacked out on drugs and alcohol.
Cerebellum smaller.
So I've got really bad balance,
you know,
simple accommodations in the workplace.
Some people like got to get away from the 60 cycle fluorescent lights.
They get quiet place to work,
open office plan,
and I got to do serious writing.
Doesn't work.
The other thing that doesn't work,
if people are kind of on the autism spectrum,
it's a sudden change in work routine.
They come into work and they just go,
okay,
we're yanking out all the office cubicles today and we're going to move them.
Okay.
If we're going to do that,
let's have some warning,
maybe a week at least a warning.
And I still can't tolerate scratchy call scratch close.
Just a horrible like sand paper.
Some cotton itches,
other cotton doesn't itch.
Now the thing is,
it's okay for Geeks to cry when the space shuttle that shutdown,
there were a lot of people crying on 60 minutes and I got thrown out of the
large girl's school for throwing a book at a girl teased me and what I want to
boarding school,
I got in fist fight in the cafeteria after guy.
He called me some names and they took horseback riding away for two weeks.
I still had to clean the barn,
but no horseback riding.
Um,
some always switched to crying.
It's okay for Geeks to cry.
That's perfectly okay.
And I would go and hide the electrical room because the tech companies don't
tolerate any violence.
Um,
I have to say that I made me shuffled to look in the clean room at JPL and
here's this big giant craftsman tool chest there.
The thank that bolts on the Mars lander.
What tightened to buy a tool kept in a craftsman tool chest,
but you better not throw that tool and why is it's by by job.
It's that simple.
It takes a village to raise a child.
We got to figure out how we can all work together to make things work because
I'm seeing too many smart kids going down the wrong road.
You don't like go to the gifted meeting.
He's going down one road.
I go to the autism meeting and,
and you've got one situation where a kid did ought to be headed for Google is
putting a class with kids that don't talk.
Then I go to another school system and he's headed in the right direction really
beautifully.
It's very,
very,
very variable.
What these two silos don't talk because if I look at the book table for the
gifted meeting and the autism meeting,
there might be a 5% overlap in the books.
That should be more like a 25% overlap in the books.
They are not talking to each other.
We got to get people to gather you all.
As I say,
one deek goes to Google on Silicon Valley,
maybe JPL,
there's another good dig the goes to Hollywood and that stuff and unfortunately
there's a brilliant cake dead.
So I go into the basement and play video games for 10 hours a day and he gets
social security for it.
That's not where I want him going.
No,
we've got to like reach out and get to these kids and you know what?
We've got to hook them in middle school.
Middle School is where we got to hook them
and some states now I'll put the skilled trades back in.
Okay.
I think that kind of on finishes up what I have to say,
but I got time for questions.
Always like to do some questions.
[inaudible]
I'm curious,
uh,
over the course of your career,
you've shared a lot of the insights you had about the experience of animals and
slaughterhouses.
I'm curious about what kinds of things you learned over your career.
Like where maybe you can look back on some of your earlier where I can see like,
oh,
this is what I understand so much more deeply now.
Yeah.
Well,
there's a lot of things.
I mean,
one thing when I,
in the 70s my first professional group was the American Society of agricultural
engineering.
I thought I could fix the world with engineering.
I absolutely believe that everything can be fixed with engineering.
I now realize only half of it can be fixed with engineering,
and I had a major equipment failure,
which was a real epiphany.
I was hired by a company in 1982 on the old slaughter plants,
saw the pigs,
had to walk up to the third floor and a real old plants and they wanted to build
a conveyor system to put in the floor of the shoot,
takes pigs up this ramp and my office and all design that.
Well,
the problem is it flipped all the pigs over backwards and it did not work and we
had to tear it out.
But then I started realizing,
no,
why are some pigs not capable of walking up this ramp?
Well,
I start getting the ID numbers off of the different pigs and I found out that
all pigs,
they had a problem,
came from one farm and they had a genetic problem called Spratto,
like where the hips are very right week.
What I should've done by trying to make it conveyor that was treating a symptom
of a problem,
we should have gone back to the source for fraction of the cost of this mess
that we had.
We could've bought that farm new bores,
like five or six new bores,
all would have taken just a few thousand dollars hey on died,
gotten rid of that genetic problem.
What assaulted.
One thing I learned from that is you've got to treat the problem at its source
rather than treating a symptom of a problem.
Now,
I want a lot of six months of depression over that.
That was not fun,
but I learned a really important lesson from that.
Thank you.
We're out of time now,
so please everybody join me in thanking Temple Grandin for coming to door
[inaudible].
Okay.